you've shown a lot of versatility over
your 10 year screen career but it all
started for you in 2007 as I understand
it Suzy figures the casting director
from the UK he's fantastic you know a
great deal was looking to cast two young
boys in a film and independent film
called son of Rambo Rambo with the W at
the end and and they came around to my
school I think had a kind of sort of
last-ditch attempt to find who they were
looking for just because as I say my
school wasn't necessarily a performance
school and they were also looking for a
young sort of cockney kid so they were
typically looking in the East End of
London and they hadn't sort of come West
at all anyway I was literally in a I
believer
an English lesson and my very eccentric
lovely drama teacher Laura slammed a
piece of paper on the window with
audition at three o'clock written on it
it was giving this window trying to sort
of pay attention and I'm there and for
for the next sort of you know 30 minutes
or whatever it was you know and it felt
like forever I was thinking I'm gonna go
on an audition I've never been on one of
those borders but I've got to get out of
double French it's that kind of got and
that so that's what I was excited about
and I went you know not thinking
anything would come of it just kind of
excited to perform in front of a camera
for the first time in my life you know
they filmed the audition and then I kind
of kept slipping through the net and
going through these different phases and
ended up sort of chemistry reading as
they say with the amazing bill Milner
who who is the son of Rambow and I just
remember my mum getting a call one day
after this sort of final stage of the
audition and my mom was on the phone in
the kitchen and she just said he didn't
and they said something to the effect
that if he did and then he and she said
he didn't and my mother said that maybe
14 times before she put down the phone
which you know not that she's doubted me
but it was you know an amazing
unthinkable sort of thing to happen and
I was very lucky and I proceeded to have
kind of the best eight weeks of my life
shooting in and I'm very lucky that my
you know entry into the industry was as
wholesome and kind of
well parented you know by golf Jennings
and Nick Goldsmith the creators and son
of Rambow just became this sort of kind
of little little engine that could and
and it was wild talk about an astronaut
you were virtually you know on the
shuttle next because you go on to the
Chronicles of Narnia franchise with a
role in voyage of the Dawn Treader so
you as a kid I understand were a huge
fan of sort of Narnia what was it like
finding yourself as part of this magical
world really bizarre you know I mean I
kind of don't pay much attention to the
budgets of a film but it but it's it's
it was kind of strange going from it
from a movie that you know we made on
the sort of lunch budget of you know
Narnia to this huge gigantic set on the
coast of Australia you know and I was 16
and it meant that my mom and my sister
my dad for some part had to you know
move with me and my older brother and
sister she stayed home but you know that
really does you know I think sort of
example of why I just how supportive
they were of me they literally packed up
their lives and moved to the other side
of the world where as far as they far
away from London is you get and it was
it was an amazing opportunity you know
I'd I'd seen the line in which the
Wardrobe is one of the most kind of
cherished of works of children
literature or just literature you know
in history so took him to be in the film
adaptation of one of those books was was
wild and it was a very maturing
experience Michael Apted the director
didn't really treat me like a like a
like a kid he might argue he might well
off but I I got the opportunity to kind
of be an adult on that on that sir even
though I was playing a real kind of
juvenile brat you know he didn't
actually give me a lot of praise and
didn't really um didn't really put his
arm round me in a way he sort of forced
me into a position where I had to prove
my Worth and you know the end of a take
it was head
we're moving on it wasn't kind of
mollycoddling sort of situation and I'm
really grateful for that you know that
kind of tough love and more adult
interaction was was was really helpful
another ælis director Kathryn Bigelow
who you just mentioned hires you for
Detroit in perhaps not the most obvious
role for you
as a redneck racist bully boy Cobb you
were so completely hateful in that movie
I feel like to move the chair it's
further away but first of all how much
of a gift or a challenge is it as an
actor to play such the opposite of
yourself a character I presume with such
psychopathic tendencies you can't relate
to him in any way you know I've played
less than likable characters before but
I think it was virtually impossible to
find an entry point into this character
because there was nothing that I could
really relate to
there was no element of his
psychological makeup a personality that
I recognized in myself and there was
much less that I could respect you know
even when I've played less unlikable
characters I've been able to identify
something and I think you hear a lot of
actors and understandably so talk about
the need to sort of respect their
character I think the second I kind of
over distilled the racist rhetoric down
to it being a kind of self-righteous
ignorance because that's effectively
what it is to me I mean racist people
are wildly misguided and some of the
most misinformed human beings on planet
earth and they've learnt this poisonous
behavior they've they've been taught
this mythology about people of color and
the threat that they supposedly posed to
to white people the second I realized
that my character thinks he's right
wholeheartedly and the thought that he
might be entirely wrong does not even
cross his mind I was onto something
and you see it echoed in society you
know all too frequently and you can go
on YouTube and you can watch interviews
with individuals who think the same way
as my character and they operate today
you know in society they walk among us
this it's terrifying so unfortunately
there was enough material there in the
research process to start building the
flesh around the skeleton that was Kraus
and and and by the way that that does a
disservice to what was an incredibly
well formed character on the page
actually you know all the writer takes a
kind of journalistic approach to his
writing and everything is so well
researched and so well fleshed out I
mean this character jumps off the page
as a monster already really it was
sometimes as simple as just saying the
things that you said saying using some
of that dehumanizing language and that
wildly misguided talk how do you reflect
on the journey you've made and what's
your vision of the next ten years I Wow
yeah I don't know that's what's scary I
really don't know you know I have
remained very aware of how lucky I've
been up until this point and I don't
want it to slip away I'm keen on as I
say trying to be you know fulfill my
potential as a creative and I don't mean
just as far as what I can offer
entertainment wise I think as far as
sort of you know speaking to what's
going on outside of the walls of the
movie theater and you know I very
luckily just worked with Lenny Abramson
on a project called the Little Stranger
we're actually reunited a domhnall
gleeson which was fantastic and Ruth
Wilson's in that project Charlotte
Rampling so yeah you know what I'm doing
in that one I'm very very very lucky
that's that's coming out next year and
beyond that you know I'm kind of waiting
to see and find out but just came to you
know keep working hard and
and heap up every opportunity that comes
my way well we look forward to
everything you do in the future thank
you appreciate thanks so much for having
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]